[Music]
i've always been inspired or fascinated
by weather
what does a cloud sound like
you know even as a child i can remember
sitting out on the grass and looking up
at the clouds as i go past what kind of
sound would those clouds output using a
piano if they if they roll across the
keys
[Music]
my name is david bowen
i'm a studio artist and educator
i make kinetic and robotic sculpture and
often these robotic devices respond to
some sort of natural input
cloud piano is a robotic installation
that plays the piano based on the
movement and density of the clouds as i
move across the sky
as you can see it's a device that mounts
to the keyboard of a piano and there's
another component a camera that's
mounted outside the building here and as
clouds go past the camera
the video is sent in real time to a
computer that then scales the data what
i've done is taken the video feed from
the camera and chopped it into 88
individual pieces as if they are the 88
keys on the the keyboard so as the
clouds go past a particular key that key
is pressed and so it's basically a
simple algorithm i suppose that says if
you see more white than blue in this
little section of the video then press
that key
i guess you could think of it then as
maybe a collaboration where i set up
this certain situation and i'm making
these choices but
after that it's kind of up to the
weather
these
odd
sounds that the piano is making continue
to build or dissipate or move and change
shape
machines or computers are thought to be
very orderly and very precise and
likewise nature is thought to be very
chaotic what keeps me interested is i
think there's a lot of
systematic ways to look at these things
that we associate with chaos
[Music]
you